on monday san ysidro the biggest land
border crossing in the western
hemisphere went back to something like
normal
the pandemic restrictions that the u.s
had placed on its southern border with
mexico were finally
eased
for international trade that won't mean
much mexico's mighty border factories
the machiladores had already been
allowed to cross their goods into the us
for the past year
but it's the so-called non-essential
travelers mexican locals and tourists
who've now been cleared to visit as long
as they're fully vaccinated
innis is one of many in tijuana who's
been counting down the days the first
thing that i'm gonna do is
cross cross with my kids and
take the opportunity to to um
take the vaccination for them
uh in mexico we don't have that
opportunity are there many people in
your family as well that are all friends
that have been waiting for this
opportunity to cross the border for
whatever reason as well
see
glad
yes of course all of my friends want to
go shopping and many people who have
family there want to see them again and
have the life we had before it's really
exciting
california's border businesses will be
excited to see them again too without
their mexican customers hundreds closed
down during the pandemic
but in tijuana it's been quite the
opposite restaurants have benefited from
americans heading across to dine in a
country where restrictions are not as
strict
people i think we're tired of
eating home
and and and they start
coming over here to tijuana because
they're free
to sit over
here
now sergio and other restaurant tours
are hoping the u.s visitors will keep
coming and that locals won't abandon
them now they're free to head to the
states
there will be a 50 increase in traffic
heading across the border tijuana
authorities believe
but many waiting on the streets or
intense for their chance to cross won't
be able to join that rush
this is a camp of asylum seekers who
want to get into the united states but
the easing of the pandemic restrictions
aren't going to make any difference for
them and it's a reminder that covid
isn't the only issue at this border
there's also migration and it will
continue to be so even when the pandemic
is long gone
these people are stuck
at the only crossing point to the us in
tijuana which remains closed while the
rest of the border gets moving again
john holman al jazeera tijuana